I'm now going to telephone
a colleague of mine
and he happens to be
the director of research
of the Post Office.
And with a bit of luck
I'll be able to telephone him here.
I'll have a go anyway.
I'll switch it on
and you can hear the noise.
And I'm now going to dial,
[MECHANICAL CLICKING NOISE]
you can hear it.
[RINGING NOISE]
[STATIC NOISE]
He's answered, hello Professor Bray?
[SLIGHTLY DISTORTED AUDIO]
– Hello Geoffrey, how good to see you
as well as hear you.
– Well isn't it remarkable,
now this is a surprise
you see, I pick up a telephone
and now I see you sitting there.
Professor Bray look, we're going to want
to talk to you a little more
about this remarkable thing
the videophone.
But I've just been talking
about fibre optics and I think
that you at [INAUDIBLE] are rather
interested in fibre optics too,
am I right?
– We are indeed Geoffrey,
and I shouldn't be surprised
one day you know,
to see these viewphone pictures
coming into people's homes
through a glass fibre.
But not only that of course,
providing them with telephone communication
and vision communication
as well.
– How very interesting.
Well now look there's
somebody here I think
would like to ask you a question.
Yes here we are.
Now if I press this button
'self-view' I believe,
I can see myself
and with a bit of luck
I'm going to see you too.
so I'm going to try it .
And you come down,
oh there we can see each other.
And you can still see us?
– Yes I can see you fine.
Well isn't that remarkable.
Now you ask a question
we'll go back to Professor Bray.
You ask, what was your question?
Oh yes you want the phone don't you,
of course.
[LAUGHTER]
– Hello sir
– Hello Matthew
– Can you tell me when video phones
will be in our homes?
Well the one we're using now Matthew
is quite an experimental one,
and it'll take a few years
to turn this into a device
which is low enough in cost
for people to use on a large scale
but it will not be many years
I think before a view phone
will come into service.
– How much will it cost?
– Well that's rather a difficult question
at this stage,
clearly it's got be a cost that
people can afford
in terms of the service
the view phone will provide.
– Thank you very much.
– Thank you Matthew.
Well thank you very much John,
a couple of very awkward questions
when are thing's
right in the research phase.
[LAUGHS]
– It is in the research phase
as you say Geoffrey, but
there are many developments
of viewphone that I think
would interest people,
I expect it to be able to provide
in clear, high definition,
copies of documents for example.
And by pressing a button
to get a printed copy when you want it.
– How very useful.
– For business people you see,
as well as people in the home,
I think this is going to be
a very important communication tool
of the future.
– Well I'm gonna say
thank you very much John
for talking to us and hang up,
good bye.
–Thank you Geoffrey, good bye.
– Switch it off.
[APPLAUSE]